so now let me go ahead and I can use my
future value idea I can say the future
value will be equal to some repayment
times and we have tables for this right
you've ever took us ages to do it line
by line especially my goodness it is 240
line that's on the sound like fun but
that's why we have these tables yeah
we've calculated the numbers that are
going to be useful to us so now go to
your future value table so this is you
Peter yes okay so have a look can you
see the right row and the right column
that I myself yes look 240 in here and
I'm going to count across 20.4% and Eve
that number there is about four hundred
and one point six seven five zero okay
now before we go on please please please
think about what this is saying right
what this is saying is there's some
repayment that's the number trying to
work out which is why I've written
rehave it because I don't know what to
do and after 240 lots of this zero point
four percent interest I want it to get
to this future value right because
that's the actual depth and I'll end up
paying off or full-width and up there
you go okay so therefore the future
value is going to be seven five five
point nine point three and percent is
your payment times that so therefore if
what I'm trying to do is make the
retainer the subject sold or three
papers and what must I do both eyes if I
say that I divide by four hundred one
point six seven five
that's a common equals okay well you're
1/8 yeah yes okay so what are we just
established this is the monthly
repayment such that if I don't at 240
months 20 years and I get 0.4% knickers
for each of my new tables if I hear this
or at full pay like this then eventually
in 20 years it will be worth this which
is a huge sum of money it much bigger
money borrowed but that's what the
amount is borrowed also grows into does
that make sense so his debt has grown
over 20 years but his repayment will
also grow according to the future value
so okay so that's theater however this
is a long way to go about this okay it's
correct however we've actually learned
something that will do a bit of a shock
up for us okay inside need here of
getting to the figure at the future
value and it's sort of backtracking to
see exactly what present value is about
doom number how we worked at present
value we thought about the future value
and then we try to reverse-engineer the
compound interest formula okay which is
exactly what we've done here you've gone
to the future and then sort of step back
in time okay so another way of getting
the same number which is more efficient
but it's a bit counterintuitive is now
just put on the side here quicker method
we calculated that it's better the
future value table I want you to come
board a few pictures to you print oh
okay so now I just want to make sure
that I'm working at the right partner
yeah good now I want you to think about
it this way instead of going all in time
to imagine what will your best become
and then work out your repayment okay
instead I'm going to say that the future
value is going to each science of the
future the present value like what you
have to what fall has to pay off right
now
every time today is going to be entering
payment time and again I need to look at
the table for the appropriate value okay
so I'm still going to 40 and still going
to 0.4%
so on this table at a different spot a
certain different options the first
column and come all the way down to
cheap oil now it's a different number of
course a different number because I'm
thinking about it in a different way
right the number is 1 5 4 0 9 3 okay so
the repayment is going to need to get to
the present value of $290,000 right it's
like if you had children 8,000 invested
it today 209,000 this is the different
value I'm going to divide by which kind
of automate all this workbook so I'm
going to proceed through the equation
just like I did before but my numbers
are all a bit different
now if we brand our table correctly and
please go ahead and verify this on your
calculator when you go ahead and crunch
$290,000 divided by hundred fifty four
point zero nine three three you should
end up here so has not yes wonderful
okay now why did I show you in both ways
personally I like this way because it
shows you it helps you understand what's
happening but this thing grows and you
don't be mean to going to keep up with
them okay and eventually they will be at
this Sun this sort of feels a bit mean
to me why don't we use present values
you want to remember it this way it's
because form is prepaid in present day
right so he has to keep on making those
repayments and this is where you're
going to end up
it's truly faster but if you find it
easier to understand this then I'll do
it this way because it's more an
adventure on this game going on then
that you just get a right number at the
end okay so we conclusion when you're
trying to repay alone you can use either
the future value or with present value
table so long did you do it to the
correct number okay so have a look see
this number here this number is a number
in the future that he will have paid off
so that's why I use the future value
table this number here is how much she
owes right now today he he just borrowed
it okay so mean this is a debt that he
has at present he used the present moto
does that make sense so the key for
these questions as we come back to a a
already written down the question but
like the job or the key for these
questions is just to think about are you
in the present is your debt in the
present or is your debt in the future
and that will tell you you lose 10
communities okay